after rocking the Rumba alfonso ribeiro
revealed a big secret on Dancing with
the Stars hey guys i'm sylva shall AC
with trending on 80 now Alfonso and his
pro partner Whitney danced away with an
impressive 36 out of 40 score on Monday
night but it was Alfonso's big
announcement that got viewers excited
take a look 36 out of 40 I know that's a
good number but I know there's another
number you want to talk about tonight
well yes my my son it's his first
birthday today so I'm so happy that he's
here with me and as a wonderful present
my wife and I decided to get him a
little brother or sister having a baby
to announce it here on the show because
I just want to say thank you to all the
fans and but I love my wife and we now
you may need a snap today well hopefully
this thing still works okay well it
seems like it dies both for them Tom now
if you didn't catch that last reference
check out what happened during
rehearsals last week that get you on
your side notice okay yeah be right ouch
well hey at least Alfonso NAB's the
evening second-highest score so I guess
it was worth it
but seriously congratulations to the
Ribeiro family and if you just can't get
enough celebrity baby news ET online has
got you covered